herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
von der hallo deutsch schule
heute sprechen wir über das thema
unfälle und wie man einen krankenwagen
rufen
sprechen wir über das thema unfälle und
wie man einen krankenwagen rufen
und jetzt viel spaß und film ab
diese sandwich schmeckt köstlich schatz
sandwich schmeckt köstlich schatz
es freut mich dass es der schmeckt
ich gehe kurz runter in den keller
ich muss noch die wäsche aus dem
trockner nehmen
in ordnung ruf mich wenn du meine hilfe
brauchst
enorm
ruf mich wenn du meine hilfe brauchst
die lampe scheint defekt zu sein
liebling kannst du bitte kurz runter in
den keller kommen
ich komme gleich
ich komme
nur noch mein sandwich
ich esse nur noch mein sandwich
das sandwich
war sehr lecker
du hast nach mehr gerufen
das licht funktioniert nicht
kannst du dir das bitter anschauen
das ist unmöglich ich habe die glühbirne
gerade erst gewechselt
[Musik]
liebling sei so gut und bring mir bitte
kurz die leiter
so gut und bring mir bitte kurz die
leiter
im ernst ich glaube das schaffst du auch
selber
ich bin dann mal oben in der küche
ruf mich wenn ich dir etwas helfen kann
also dann ran an die arbeit
die glühbirne scheint defekt zu sein
was macht er denn da unten so lange
ich schaue besser kurz nach
vielleicht braucht er meine hilfe
ach du schreck was ist denn hier los
oh nein robert was ist geschehen
worauf liebling
wach auf liebling
ich muss dringend einen krankenwagen
rufen
sie sprechen mit der notrufzentrale vom
spital in zürich
wie kann ich ihnen behilflich sein
wie kann
behilflich sein
guten tag bitte schicken sie uns einen
krankenwagen
es ist dringend
bitte beruhigen sie sich gute frau sagen
sie mir bitte ihren namen
mein name ist frau gerber
[Musik]
von wo
wenn sie uns an frau gerber
finden sie uns an frau gerber
wir wohnen an der muster straße 24
ich sehe sie wohnen in einem reihenhaus
in welchem haus wohnen sie genau
wir wohnen an der münsterstraße 24b das
haus auf der rechten seite
[Musik]
wir wohnen an der muster straße 24 b das
haus auf der rechten seite
sagen sie mir
doch ihre telefonnummer
dennoch ihre telefonnummer
meine telefonnummer lautet 0 7344 51 32
vielen
frau gerber bitte erzählen sie mir jetzt
genau was passiert ist
vielen dank frau gerber bitte erzählen
sie mir jetzt genau was passiert ist
mein mann war im keller und hat eine
lampe repariert
jetzt liegt er bewusstlos auf dem boden
was soll ich tun
bleiben sie ganz ruhig frau gerber der
krankenwagen ist unterwegs
stellen sie ihr telefon auf lautsprecher
und legen sie es neben sich auf den
boden
stellen sie ihr telefon auf lautsprecher
und legen sie es neben sich auf den
boden
ist ihr mann ansprechbar
ist ihr mann
sichtbar
einen augenblick
nein er ist bewusstlos was soll ich nur
machen
bitte schauen sie ob ihr mann noch atmet
wenn sie dafür ihre hand auf seine brust
legen sie dafür ihre hand auf seine
brust
sie können auch ihre finger unter seine
nase halten um eine atmung festzustellen
ich glaube er atmet
ja ich bin sicher dass er noch atmet
ja ich bin sicher dass er noch art mit
sehr gut frau gerber bitte bringen sie
ihren mann nun in eine stabile
seitenlage
sehr gut frau gerber bitte bringen sie
ihren mann nun in eine stabile
seitenlage
so sorgen wir dafür dass die atemwege
nicht blockiert werden
so sorgen
das die atemwege nicht blockiert werden
er ist jetzt in der stabilen seitenlage
was soll ich jetzt tun
streck
wenn sie jetzt den kopf ihres mannes
leicht nach hinten und öffnen sie seinen
mund
können sie jetzt den kopf ihres mannes
leicht nach hinten und öffnen sie seinen
mund
wenn wir das die zunge die atemwege
blockiert
durch verhindern
wir dass die zunge die atemwege
blockiert
außerdem
kann so flüssigkeit aus dem mund
abfließen
dem kann so flüssigkeit aus dem mund
und was muss ich jetzt machen
bleiben sie bei ihrem mann und
kontrollieren sie regelmäßig seine
atmung
bleiben sie
man und kontrollieren sie regelmäßig
seine atmung
der kranken war
gehen wird jede minute bei ihnen
eintreffen
der kranken
wird jede minute bei ihnen eintreffen
ich bin so nervös
[Musik]
das ist ganz nah
sie machen das super
[Musik]
das ist ganz
sie machen das super
[Musik]
weiter die atmung ihres mannes und
bleiben sie ganz ruhig frau gerber
kontrollieren sie weiter die atmung
ihres mannes und bleiben sie ganz ruhig
frau gerber
ich glaube ich höre die sirenen des
krankenwagens
[Musik]
ich glaube ich höre die sirenen des
krankenwagens
[Musik]
sehr gut frau gerber sie können jetzt
auflegen und die sanitäter einweisen
auf wiederhören und vielen dank für ihre
hilfe
auf wiederhören frau gerber und alles
gute
[Musik]
das war unser video zum thema unfälle
ich hoffe es hat dir gefallen
übrigens hast du
elfen im video gefunden
[Musik]
übrigens hast du alle elf in im video
gefunden
wo hast du die elfen gefunden
schreibe es in die kommentare
[Musik]
hier nochmal einige begriffe aus diesem
video
das
[Musik]
die wäsche
der trockner
[Musik]
die lampe
die glüht
dr
die glühbirne
der krankenwagen
das reihenhaus
die atmung
atmen
die stabile sei
frage
die stabile seitenlage
bis zum nächsten
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video